they come from every corner of the world
to make a better life for themselves in
Germany but the Germans aren't sure what
to think of the latest wave of
emigration we don't have enough skilled
workers in the future and immigration
can help with that I'm welcoming I'm
always excited to get to know people
from other countries and other
nationalities I don't like it
we've got enough people in this country
with problems we have enough poverty
according to a new academic study one in
two Germans say that immigration can
help Germany combat the strain of an
ageing society and a lack of skilled
workers but two-thirds also viewed
increased immigration as a challenge for
Germany's social system and said that
immigration can lead to conflicts with
native-born Germans the biggest problem
is the language without communication
immigrants can't integrate into society
I'm Arabic and I speak my own language
but at the same time I'm German and I
think immigrants need to assimilate
Indian descent I believe Germany would
be nothing without immigrants I believe
we need immigration everyone makes sure
people feel at home then it will work
out for the best